tu es un petit peu à tout le monde on a
pris alors la marche à suivre je dirai
tout à fait logique c'est à dire qu'on a
commencé par ce qu'on appelait autrefois
les trois jours je sais pas s'il
s'appelle toujours comme ça d'ailleurs
parce que s'en fait en fait fait deux
demi journées
nous sommes allés à rennes où on fait
une sorte de bilan de premier bilan d
aptitude physique et mentale de ceux qui
iront servir sous les drapeaux
quelques mois après un reportage de
frédérique sto et frédéric basket 8
heures du matin
un premier groupe de jeunes venus de
douze départements de l'ouest de la
france arrive au centre de sélection à
rennes pendant toute la journée ils vont
passer des tests d'aptitude qui leur
permettront ensuite d'être orientés vers
l'une des trois armées la marine
l'aviation où l'armée de terre avait
l'impression qu'ils vont être très très
sévère lors la dans l'examen de votre
état de santé de vos aptitudes ou lourde
et ou pages de ses pages
s'il me fit l'expérience mon frère qui a
été exempté pour des réseaux de titres
si j'ai autant de chance c'est tant
mieux autrement ça m'étonnerait si vous
aviez le choix ou pourriez ne pas le
faire
moi ça me met également fin mais
personnellement je préfère le boss ne
pas le faire si vous pouviez échapper ça
vous donc à part moi je trouve que
l'armée il faut le faire c'est pas il
faut pas chercher à se faire réformer
c'est comme ça c'est important pour vous
aider dans votre famille votre entourage
de faire le service militaire
je ne répondrai pas à cette question
faut le faire y'a pas de merfy difficile
de répondre spontanément quand on est si
près d'un groupe d'officiers à
l'intérieur du bâtiment l'accueil est
plutôt bon enfant
donc j'ai une ambiance de rentrée des
classes il faut d'abord répondre à
l'appel après c'est la répartition
l'équipe commander chacune par un gradé
ils sont ainsi plus de 300 à faire en
une journée ce que l'on appelait
autrefois les trois jours ce système de
sélection vous êtes mis en circuit dans
tout ce qu'il ya des attentes et un
dernier en étape du circuit une réunion
d'information sur l'organisation de la
journée et sur les différentes
possibilités d'affectation
lors de l'appel sous les drapeaux la
tête c'est maintenant que les choses
sérieuses commencent
les premiers tests médicaux chaque
examen est destiné à mesurer la capacité
des futurs appelé à remplir ou non une
fonction dans l'armée dans certains cas
il ne faut être ni trop petit ni trop
grand on sait que pour les charles
taille limitée
1 mètre 80 de plus à un sélectionné ne
peut faire son armée que s'il mesure
plus d'un mètre cinquante quatre pour
des raisons militent et s'il fait plus
de vingt 80 ou veut dire que pas rentrer
dans le chat non c'est des raisons
apparemment évidente suivant s'il vous
plaît après la taille les oreilles vous
entraînant qu'elle va essayer il s'agit
de déterminer un audiogramme étudier le
plus petit sans qu'ils puissent entendre
en partant des fréquences les plus
graves vers les séquences les plus aigus
en ayant des normes bien précises de
limites audition qui nous permet de
déterminer leur aptitude au service
bilba la possibilité de s'abriter le ts
s'il en a envie puisque c'est lui qui
doit se manifester
pas si vous voulez les tests une fois
qu'ils sont effectués ici
bon si ton pathologique passe devant le
médecin nous nous refusons des têtes
mais examinons donc a priori on peut
également déterminer si la fraude points
vous connaissez un peu les petites
ficelles de le sait par expérience de
ceux qui veulent une bonne idée mais
attention ici on n'exempte pas celui
qu'ils considéraient comme inaptes dans
un centre de sélection on se contente de
faire des propositions d'aptitude ou
d'inaptitude à l'aide des bilans de
santé qui concernent chaque année à
rennes
soixante mille jeunes pour établir ces
bilans les médecins militaires s'appuie
sur le règlement il permet d'attribuer
une note d'aptitude dans une fourchette
de 1 à 6 ensuite c'est au bureau du
service national de prendre les
décisions en fonction des besoins des
armées et des limites fixées par le
ministère encore faut-il que ces notes
ne soit pas ensuite modifié l'année
dernière un trafic a été découvert au
centre de sélection de cambrai deux
aspirants médecins truquée les tests de
certains fils à papa pour leur permettre
d'échapper au service militaire au
centre de blois s'est appelés du
contingent chargé de mettre en mémoire
informatique
les résultats des tests se livrer aux
mêmes trafic
depuis les autorités militaires ont pris
leurs précautions aujourd'hui lorsqu'une
cause d'exemption apparaît durant la
sélection dans le dossier d'un jeune
appelé celui ci doit se rendre dans le
bureau d'un médecin expert qui pourra
soit confirmé le diagnostic soit
demander un nouvel examen sur place ou
dans un hôpital militaire de plus c'est
le médecin expert qui transmettra
lui-même à l'ordinateur
la proposition d'exemption intentions
vous avez 35 minutes pour faire cette
épreuve
prenez vos crayons ouvrez vos cahiers
commencé après les tests médicaux
les tests d'aptitudes intellectuelle
pour mesurer le sens de la logique et
l'intelligence pratique du futur soldat
est ce que ce sont des tests en cas
d'échec ou en cas de mauvais résultats
qui peuvent déboucher sur une exemption
non pas du tout si le jeune n'a pas pu
répondre à toutes les questions et
obtient un niveau très bas
il sera renvoyé dans le circuit médical
pour contrôler sa déficience
psychologique ou cesse outre entrer une
fois les tests terminés
chaque sélectionné termine son circuit
par le bureau de cet officier
c'est lui qui va l'orienter en l'aidant
à demander l'affectation de son choix ou
à faire certaines démarches par exemple
pourra dispenser les services militaires
tout dépend des résultats de ces tests
de sa situation sociale et bien sûr ils
besoin des armes et des adresses où ils
peuvent savourer c'est comme par exemple
la coopération à paris on va leur
fournir les papiers qu'il faut renvoyer
pour demander un report incorporation si
ce n'est pas maintenant faut le demander
par exemple au mois de juin au mois
d'août pour l'année d'après et ensuite
ils se débrouillent avec les adresses et
les papiers qu'on leur fournit
est ce que vous savez quelle quelle
démarche vous avez à faire après pour
partir à la lèvre qui vous arrange
et vous avez vous informer et vous savez
comment le faire non
alors comment allez vous vous informez
vous a pas dit à quel endroit vous
adresser non vous allez le demander je
pas demain dans les jours qui viennent
et le chapeau leur reportage de
frédérique as tout est fait avec basket
à rennes avant de poursuivre sur ce
reportage ou pas de questions vous dire
qu'on est